it's a great add to the Capitals lineup
brings a lot of energy brings great stick
work bang bang play there for Oshi jamed
that one wide With a Little Help from eigor
shurkin in the cage tonight for New York
Carlson walks the line threads the needle
farar to the front Milano he scores
a beautiful play 43 seconds into the
contest the Caps are 60 and2 when scoring
first have not lost in regulation what a
pass all the way around there everybody was
involved Carlson that is serious sauce hits
will are coming across as farari and that
farari a freezing goalie pass notice as the
goenda but then he went seven straight games
without registering a point Ryan lingren lets this
one fly brother Charlie there to make the stop if
you joined us a little late it took Sunny Milano
all of 43 seconds to score from farari and Carlson
ohh she down the wing from the severe angle no
troubles there for just Durkin trying to get his
excitement and energy level up and TJ Oshi missing
the game for six he's excited to be playing here
tonight Miller snapshot glove by Charlie lingren
he'll hold have crder on the other side they
have a lot of Talent on that line Jensen will
advance on for Dylan stro the Caps leading goal
score rolls his path to the slot snapped on by
Edmonson at the goal line here it bounces wide the
back games here's Edmonton Edmonson shot deflected
by Wilson in front off the defenseman Snider and
Obie right in front rolls off the back of the left
shoulder out there with Will kolie and Nick Bonino
for Peter lavet Schneider lets this one fly and
Linden finds it Charlie has it in his glove Locker
on the Toyota star 924 for that save percentage of
lockers comment top six in the NHL a backhander
from pitlick loved by Charlie lingren strome
serves that one to the front blocked off by Guston
and guston's lucky he blocked that because Obie
was wide open on the far flank oetkin followup
rer he's got it right up the gut here backand
just stking the save sprawling to keep it out they
Jam for it at the post Obie gets the opportunity
here back pressure by Wilson you see the Dem man
Schneider can't clear and here comes oie a real
good stop by shurkin four points in the last five
games for the 22-year-old Bell Russian caps on the
lead one- nothing against New York the first of
four against the Rangers follow-up chance just
cker made a good save on McMichael set piece right
up the draw Panera's drive that was intercepted
by Carlson a bang bang play Here Charlie made a
great stop on leier and he'll hold yeah they're
a good hockey team top to bottom their D really
put pressure on you and that was a heck of a game
nine goals scored little bit of everything glov
save Charlie lingren on a bullet from leier yeah
he's going up each year you know he's a young guy
continues to improve points going up offensively
his first three seasons Dylan stro fires kicked
out of there by shurin who left a pretty juicy
rebound trouba on the advance with zabad he'll
launch this one to Charlie on one Skip and lingren
will hold on Spencer carbur was talking about
that earlier today with the assembled media at
MedStar as ooshi fires right off the draw shurin
wheeler 45 ticks left Edmonson plays it on Jensen
beautiful Fred the needle to OB cubel denied by
Sherin thr around the pill early on that led to
that first goal that is dynamite hitting a guy
in scene hitting him in stride and he gets a
beautiful shot [Music] away oetkin Thunders away
stop by shurin and then he turns into Dominic
hasik to put the blocking glove down on the Pucket
another go tender here it is off the draw it's he
in front OSI just about got a piece of it if he
does the save is probably a lot tougher than it
turned out to be but an excellent stop by shurin
caps getting some very high quality looks here in
the this is a New York Bunch Locker almost 90% on
the PK on the road and very very good good break
out there by the capsule oh she closing front door
great save just turkin first of four games between
these division rivals in about 5 weeks time Chris
neof slap pass down low score mantha on the tip
in watch btha just D to the net he had just
got on the ice and there's that pullup pass
by koozie CU nof was thinking of pounding it
but with his left eye sees mana and he elects
to make the pass rather than a screaming hard
Slap Shot beautiful who was racked in the first
period smashed the side of his face against the
glass Bonino turns on a wrap around and Charlie
made that save in the cover he's being called good
save on the wrap though right the paddle down no
five hole for Bonino using his size and reach to
wrap it around the Rangers get possession trouba
towards the cage hoping for a troch che deflection
poked aside by Charlie lindr slapper from Miller
armed Away by the Washington net minder the
capital Captain oetkin didn't get it clear
there panan to the interior Miller got ripped
off and Away comes Wilson this is a two-on-one
developing with lkin Wilson settles fires he
scores Tom Wilson with a cannon shot over the
glove In Their Own Zone there's the Poke check
Off to the Races and look at the get up and go
he just burns down the ice he's looking at OB
but he calls his own number see him looking
across and then he just rips it when you're
on the wrong side offside and you're a right
shot that top Corner always looks you right
in the eye yeah and I think they sense that
this is a critical stret for this hockey team
it's not do or die or anything like that but
you like to bank some points against your Metro
division F the exception tomorrow night when the
Caps see impressive rookie Conor Bard and the
Blackhawks snapshot score oy cubel with a buzz
bomb first of all you've got to beat the icing and
here's Beck hustling in beats the icing keeping
the puck alive they're moving their feet they're
skating doubt disrupts the pass around they throw
it to the front it'll be unassisted unfortunately
the way I look at it because credit goes he had 26
ppgs a couple of seasons ago for the Rangers
team an all-time high panan works it outside
box to the front looking for that chance this
rebounds off the post and here he just rifles
at one there's your guy in front krider and
there's a short side post as jaban at usually
doesn't miss that when he plays the Caps 210 left
separating us from CIS secure intermission live
Alexa and Al getting set beautiful pass there
on the front door lingren made that pad save
and Obie just buried their youngster La friend on
the close side Penalty Box doors o cuell with a
rip stop rebound off of shesterkin the followup
chance does not hit Pay Dirt it winds up off of
the rink here's a couple of looks at this last
shot Bell just shooting the buck on right around
the neck area the r the clavicle there by o cubel
he's already scored top corner on sterkin they're
looking for the same type of result yeah he just
came back to the bench he was in the locker room
getting some equipment repair three-on-one
Rangers snap shot off the bar paner and hits
the crossbar and out splendidly for Washington
making their own luck and being a little lucky
at the opposite end outd dueling eigor shurk
and fans rising to their feet the red rockers
approving of what they've seen in this one Easy
closing chance here snapped high pitlick with
help from the shoulder of lingren this is sent all
the way in right to jurkin six seconds left that's
going to do it Charlie lindr and the capitals
whitewashing the Rangers by the final of 4 nothing